I was gonna do what's in my iPhone video
but then I was looking through my apps
and they're really boring so I thought
okay cool the App Store to find some
cool apps make me seem like I'm much
cooler than I really in any way in my
search for fun new apps I started
playing with this app it's called strum
only the description you guys gonna
download it and trust me you're gonna
one download it because this is
Stephanie she's all entertained a sickly
just takes your seemingly boring
15-second video and mashes it together
Auto Tunes it and makes it into like
this mini little music video personally
show you this is the first hundun I made
it makes me feel so crazy
I mean I'm crazy but this definitely
takes it to a whole new level
then I was like okay this is pretty fun
so the people inside and then this one I
made for Ryan who is on my name is quiz
my nose favorite one that I've made is
my sister Bree who she's a pharmacist so
this is for Breda pharmacy so what I'm
gonna do is because I know most fun
thing is to make videos for other people
leave me in the comments below your name
and some things that you like and
conclude a human your video you can
follow me on strum and you can see if I
make a video for you guys today probably
be making these all day long so make
sure you guys keep your eyes peeled
while I'm gonna go play with my apps so
see you guys later
I have a cat her name is Jane she has a
hat that's a little too holiday festive
next to me is my end of the world
preparation bag I've put together a few
things and the only stipulation was it
all has to fit in this bag is really
heavy